- He's an entrepreneur,
scientist, and author.
He's the co-founder and
chairman of BodyMedia.
Since 2010, he's been directing
Google X Laboratories.
He's Astro Teller,
and here are his top 10 rules for success.
(dramatic swoosh)
- Go big or go home.
It's so easy to think
that if you play it safe,
if you do it a little
simpler, a little smaller,
you won't scare yourself,
you won't scare your friends, your family,
you won't scare your investors
when you go ask them for money.
It's just not true.
The world just doesn't work like that.
It's counterintuitive,
but you can't go too
big, you really can't.
The bigger you go the more
inspired you will be personally.
And trust me, you will need to be inspired
to get through the hard
times that will hit you.
The bigger you go the more
of a cause you can make it
for the people who you're
going to need to attract.
"Hey, come with me.
"We're going to do something
and make the world 5% better."
Eh, you know what, I'll
stay in my current job.
We're going to make the
world 10 times better.
world 100 times better.
Now you've got me.
Now it's like I'll ask
what I'm getting paid
three months after I start work, right?
That's the feeling that you need
to be able to create in people
in order for them to join you.
So go big or go home.
The second thing is failing fast.
Companies say that phrase,
but they just don't do it.
In order to do something radical,
you have to be prepared
for most of the things,
literally 99% of the things
that you do not to work out,
which is totally fine and
it's not too expensive
if you kill them at the first moment
when you could reasonably
have known to stop doing it.
But for all kinds of mostly
emotional reasons we don't.
I mean even we don't at Google X.
It's incredibly hard to make this happen.
If you're going to have a portfolio
of these more radical bets,
of trying things out,
I'm not and I assure you you're not
smart enough to figure out ahead of time
which of the hundred
things you're going to try
is the one that's going to work out.
There's just no way.
Like maybe one person in a generation,
like a Steve Jobs like person
can just point and say,
"That turns out to be the right answer."
So unless you're the Steve
Jobs of this generation,
the right answer is try
stuff, just try stuff.
But then you have to create
a culture among your people
that says, "I value you trying things.
"There's nothing wrong
with the learning moment."
The failure moment is not the moment
where we stop a project.
It is the moment when we
decide to stop a project
and realize that we
knew six months earlier,
a year and a half earlier,
that we could have killed it.
That's the failure moment,
not the moment six months
earlier or 18 months earlier
where we say, "Oh, that was worth trying.
"Didn't work out, next."
That's a learning moment.
That's not a failure moment.
The perspective shift
is what it's all about.
That why going 10 times
bigger is more important
and works better than going 10% bigger.
When you shoot for 10% better
you're in a smartness contest.
You're putting all of your people
in a smartness contest with
everyone else in the world.
They're not going to win.
It doesn't matter how
much money you give them.
But, if you push them,
if you give them the expectation
and the freedom to be weird,
that's moonshot thinking.
Then they can do the perspective shifts.
And not only if you
shoot for 10 times bigger
instead of 10% bigger,
it's almost never 100 times harder
and the payoff is 100 times,
so you already know that you've got
a better return on your investment.
But sometimes it's literally easier,
and the reason is because
that perspective shift
is actually cheap
relatively to being smarter
than everyone around you.
No excuses.
No victim mentality.
The world owes you nothing.
The world might come help you,
but I wouldn't count on it.
And if you start from the
feeling that you need
the world to participate
in order for you to be successful
at taking on this new thing
that you're considering doing,
you're right to be scared.
It might.
I wouldn't count on it though.
But if you start from the perspective
that the world owes you
nothing, which it doesn't,
and that it is not likely to
bring you any particular help,
you have nothing to lose,
because really isn't that
for every one of the people
you brought onto the team,
isn't that how you want them to feel
when they report to you?
You don't want excuses.
That doesn't mean that you can't fail
or that they can't ever fail.
But right when you're starting,
you have nothing to lose.
When you're a huge company,
you can spend 99% of your time
worrying how not to mess up
the billion dollar a year
money hose you've created.
But, you don't have a
billion dollar a year
money hose right now.
You have nothing, so you can't lose.
Spend 99% of your time
imagining what would
happen if things went well
and planning for that.
I think risk is important
for every company.
I think it is the essence
of entrepreneurship
whether you're the smallest
company in the world
or like Google the second
largest company in the world
to take smart risks over time.
I run this experiment
frequently with groups
where I give them two choices,
Choice A and Choice B.
So Choice A is you get to deliver
a million dollars of bottom line value
to your company this year, guaranteed.
Choice B you get to deliver
a billion dollars of bottom line value
to your company this year,
but only with one chance in 100.
So everyone does the mental math.
I say, "Who wants Choice A?"
Nobody raises their hand.
"Who wants Choice B?"
Everybody raises their hand.
It's got an expected utility
that's 10 times higher than Choice A.
And then I say, "Who here
believes that your boss
"wants you to choose Choice B?"
And not a single person in
the room raises their hand.
I mean these typically
are large multinationals
who want to be innovative.
And then I say, "You don't
need a lecture on innovation.
"You need a new boss.
"You need a new context."
I really think that it's
the context that matters.
We all inherently understand
that taking smart risks
is the right thing to do.
Now what counts as smart
and what counts as a risk
is different in different
parts of the company
or companies of different sizes.
You know, you can tolerate
a PR fiasco much easier
if you're a tiny company,
because no one is watching you,
than if you're a large
company for example.
So, the calculus is different,
but the principle is still the same.
The only way to stay sharp,
to stay growing, to stay relevant,
is to take smart risks all the time.
This is actually what I spend
a lot of my time on with Google X
that if we all believe that
our project has to work,
then we're going to find some way
to BS ourselves, to BS our manager
that it's going to work
even way past the point
where we know in our hearts
that it's not going to work.
And we do that because we're worried
we're going to lose our bonuses,
we're going to lose the
people who report to us,
we might lose our jobs,
we're going to lose face with our peers.
We have all these reasons
not to want to raise our hands and say,
"Look, this is a dumb one.
"Let's go do something else."
And so if you can create a culture
in which people actually believe
not that failure in the
long run is acceptable like,
"Oh, we just kind of went in
circles, but that's cool."
That's not cool.
But, if you can see each thing that you do
as a purposeful experiment,
there's no bad ...
There are bad experiments to run.
Like if you already ran the
experiment you just run it again
that's a dumb thing to do,
but there's no bad
outcome to an experiment
if it was a thoughtful experiment to run.
Think of a good question.
Think of the fastest, cheapest way
you can answer that question.
Make sure that the answer to the question
would actually change what it is
that we would do afterwards.
Go run the experiment.
And then you can celebrate
whatever the answer is afterwards.
And that way of making progress,
I think that's the rate limiting
step of real innovation.
Swim out of your element.
That's another one my favorite ones.
I chronically take on tasks
that I'm hopelessly unqualified to do,
and I do it on purpose.
So, I know that feeling
that you have inside
where you're thinking,
"Nano tech, and I know what to do,"
and then you think, "But
I don't actually know
"anything about nano tech.
"I need my head examined
for even considering
"going and changing an
industry I know nothing about."
Right?
Wrong.
Swim out of your element.
First of all, a lot of great ideas ...
You're not going to be
smarter than everybody else,
so the fact that you're not
in nano tech doesn't matter
because if you were in nano tech
you still wouldn't be in the top 10 people
in the field of nano tech.
So the fact that you aren't
the top 10 is irrelevant.
You aren't going to work
harder than everybody else.
You're probably not going to have
more funding than everybody else.
Those are not ways you
could have won anyway.
You can be more bold.
You can be more creative.
Those things you can actually do.
But you don't need to
be from their industry
in order to have those qualities.
And you can transplant
your ideas, your expertise
from an area that you are an
expert in into a new area.
If you're already in an industry
you've already been brainwashed
with the rest of the industry
into how that industry works.
Your chances of breaking that industry
and remaking it in a productive way
are actually meaningfully lower.
If you take ideas, data,
inspirations with you into a new industry
you can actually have a
perspective that they haven't had,
and that you can do.
Even if you can't be smarter,
or better funded, or work more hours,
you can have a perspective
that they don't have
because of your naivety in that industry.
So, swimming out of your element
is not a reason not to start.
It's not a handicap that you have.
You can't use it as an excuse.
It's actually your secret weapon.
You should look at that as an opportunity
to start in a new area.
Plus personally,
in any fight I'd rather be the
underdog than the champion.
It's like remember in high school
when you were like playing
against the varsity team
and you were junior varsity?
That felt awesome, because
you couldn't lose, right?
If you lost, you were supposed to lose.
And if you win, then you
get bragging rights forever.
It's the same thing.
When you enter a new industry,
you have nothing to lose.
Let's not build a prototype
and do all the easy stuff first
so that it looks like we're
making progress every week.
I don't want that,
because we're in danger of
building a ladder to the Moon
where we're closer to the Moon every week
but we're never really going to get there.
Let's work on the hardest part first.
We discuss for the project
that you're going to work on
what are the things that are most likely
to kill the project?
And I say, "Your job is not to
cause the project to succeed.
"Your job is to kill your project.
"I want you to kill your project.
"You won't be fired.
"We're just going to keep doing this."
And it is only the process of
failing to kill your project
that will eventually cause it to succeed.
So I tell you this.
You're thinking, "Does
he really mean that?
"That sounds scary."
When you do that the first couple of times
and you try an experiment,
which is functionally
what these things are,
maybe it works and we take
that risk off the list.
That's awesome.
We de-risked your project.
We try a few more and
we find the fatal flaw.
Yes indeed, this was going
to be a ladder to the Moon.
And so at Google X the mantra,
I know how Pollyannaish this sounds,
but we want to make the world
a radically better place.
And we have conversations all the time.
At the end of the conversation we say,
"Nope, that would make a
lot of money for Google.
"Wouldn't make the world
a radically better place.
"Next."
And it's joyous.
And I believe that it's actually
financially smart for Google
to have us think like that,
because then they get a bunch of people
who all are as excited as I am
to run to work in the morning
because I get to be in a place
where we get to say that to each other.
It's just so invigorating
that you get to say that
and then everyone else
starts saying it, too.
They're like, "Really?"
Because don't you all want
to be able to say that
in your daily lives
that you're not just trying to make money
for yourself or someone else,
that you want to make the world better.
It's just fundamentally inspirational.
I think it's a basic part of being a human
that we crave that like we
crave love or community.
And if you say, "That's what
we're going to be like ..."
You know, Google X is
another one of these,
this is a separate but
related Santa Clause moment.
At Google X we don't worry,
we don't work towards is probably
a better way of saying it,
how we're going to make money.
In the early conversations
about our moonshots
they do not include,
"Okay, so then it would cost us this much.
"And then we could charge that much.
"And that nets out positive."
Nope, it's the wrong
way to think about it.
Because if you're going to
make the world slightly better
then you have to claw for those pennies
that you're going to make.
That's a tough business.
It's just exhausting.
If you make the world seriously better,
10x better than the alternative,
the money will come find you.
You really don't have to figure it out.
I can see from the outside
how frustrating this looks
to watch Google do this
over and over again.
Because I think there's this attitude like
Google is just kind of bumbling its way
through the process a little bit.
But over and over again
Google has put something out in the world,
like Search, like Street View,
like Translate, Geo,
almost everything we've
done has started from a,
"You know what?
"This is just the right thing to do.
"The world is just better this way.
"Let's start by helping users,
"and then we'll figure out the money thing
"in a little while."
And that just shouldn't be true.
That's like cheating
in the business world.
There's something wrong with that.
But wouldn't that be awesome
if you could do that?
If you could actually
spend your time saying,
"Let's just make the world crazy better,"
and then trust that the money
is going to come find us?
If you want to know
what you're capable of,
look backwards, don't look forwards.
It's so easy to feel like,
"I don't know how to do it
so I won't get it done."
But that's kind of nonsensical.
You've never done this thing before.
Of course you never know
how to do the next thing.
It would be boring if you
already knew how to do it.
But look backwards at all the things
you personally have
accomplished in your life.
Imagine going back to the 20
year old version of yourself
and telling them that they
had to go do all these things.
It would sound like black magic to them,
because that person
didn't know how to do it.
You figured it out as you went.
I have a CEO that I'm mentoring,
and he called me,
and this is like two, three days ago.
And he said, "Oh God, I have
this board meeting coming up,
"and I had all these plans
"about how I was going to ask the board."
He's got an investor
who wants to put a couple
million dollars in,
but the board doesn't want
to take incremental dilution,
and he was going to like show them
all these great new results.
And he just felt like,
"You know, our revenue
has kind of been flat
"for the last couple of months.
"And I had these results and
now I can't show it to them,
"because they're not as
good as I thought they were.
"Ah, I'm just I'm so frustrated.
"I'm just, I'm no good at this."
I said, "Dave, you're
looking over the last
"like three weeks, four weeks maybe.
"You've been the CEO of this
business for 22 months."
It was already an ongoing business
when he became the CEO of it.
"The revenues of this business
"have gone up a factor 12 in 22 months.
"You've taken on one person
"and diluted the company by like 8%
"and taken up the revenues
by a factor of 12.
"Seriously, you're a loser?
"My God, we can only hope as a board
"that you'll be such a loser
for the next 22 months."
But it's easy for us to
like laugh and see that,
but you can see how in the mindset
you care about something
and you get so focused on the future
and what you don't know,
but if you look backwards
things look very different.
And often that's what
helps me to take on a task
that I don't know how to do,
because I don't have to
prove to myself I believe
that I know how to do that task.
I only have to convince myself
that I've historically done a good job
of figuring out tasks I
didn't know how to do.
(swoosh)
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video because
Blast asked me to.
So, if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of Astro Teller's top 10 rules
resonated with you the most.
Leave it in the comments.
I will join in the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe and I'll see you soon.
(dramatic swoosh)